hello happy Wednesday one day this is
week has been weird because we had
presidents day off so he's thrown off
all right we're gonna play a game that I
feel been yes people are not huge fans
of yes for reasons however yes somehow
you have found a way continue playing
despite all that I am you're gonna have
to explain that to him I don't know if
it's metal gear survive my blind love
for metal gear or something but uh you
know I I right off the bat just gonna I
think I've been having a good time with
it okay shockingly cuz like even you
probably went in as much as a middle
gear fan as you are you probably went in
going like a little like cautious
hesitant I've been I've been feeling
I've been feeling that way like all the
way up until like it's it's come out and
even still through playing it I I've had
this weird like a constant back and
forth while I've been playing it cuz
like I don't feel like I should like it
mm-hm
but I can't stop wanting to go back in
and do more
I gotcha huh I don't know if it's like
the loop of like going out and getting
things coming back to base building it
up it's it's really weird and I'm
totally risking like my Metal Gear fan
credibility like by putting it out there
so alright I hear I am yeah so just so
you guys know we as the title states
we're roughly or he is roughly 10 hours
in yeah and this is primarily
single-player obviously or well this
part of it that we're going through a
single-player there's also multiplayer
but we are going to do single-player
today and do essentially missions and
cheese your place is a lot bigger than
what I like remember seeing in like oh
my god I got so insu's I got guard
towers like how you made attacked yes so
you get attacked while you're out I
would I would assume right so it it came
up in a story part when we we got our a
wormhole generator and that is like ah
this wormhole generator sure did a thing
that it probably
supposed to do and then we had to deal
with a bunch of they're not zombies I
don't know what to call them coming in
and trying to mess with us but yeah only
one time so far though okay so otherwise
you're kind of going out probably like
what primarily like forging stuff
killing stuff yeah just grab and bulk
Ramin a lot of stuff er not very much or
Pulteney is it for thinning bolt endings
so that they don't have the full the
Fulton they've replaced it with the
upgraded wormhole yeah where my eyes
yeah same same idea you get more energy
for for using it but yeah so and you
survived what this is like six days
right because I you said they don't see
these yeah they don't do a game-time or
something that yeah I couldn't find a
way to track time so I'm six days
survived right now just going through so
this is this is the main like big weird
thing they did in the game is there's
this this fog that you have to like
venture out into and yeah it's kind of
the thing that like slows you down yes
you you have energy you you have to have
oxygen for it everything takes like
double the amount of stamina to do so
like I've I've had to teach myself to
jog which is weird not great but it's
kind of interesting because it kind of
builds tension a bit and that's the
survival survival game hello Jared tribe
hello man in the suit hello everyone in
chat in YouTube twitch GameSpot
appreciate you guys stopping by there we
go we Colton him through a wormhole
we're alive everyday at 11 a.m. so
please come back hit that sub button or
follow button if you haven't already we
play a variety of games usually we play
you know the games that are being
released that week to kind of give you a
like a preview or like a little what the
hell is that by the way I was really
kind of hoping that we wouldn't run into
this or an elephant
look Cthulhu ass monster that keeps
showing up and I'm guessing you can't do
[ __ ] against a rock I don't want to try
okay that's there maybe at the end of
the stream
try to try to see what we can do
although what we could do is see one of
those things where you save it and then
like oh yeah like if we just go kill
them or try to kill them that you then
don't lose your progress I don't want
you to like you can do a thing so that's
this is really interesting you don't
even see like the full part of the the
thing this is just the tail end yeah
it's actually like super super long it's
really weird-looking you can take you to
hunt I got it with my my what is it my
my common level gun here and bow and
arrow
I've got we're hunting your arrows he's
got a gold bat though hold on I love my
gold bet it's great but yeah so
basically we stream a lot of the like
the games that are you know out that
week or betas or alphas or demos if we
have them early or anything like that to
try to give you some insight on you know
if maybe you want to play the game or
buy the game obviously GameSpot does
reviews as well well we will have a
review in progress hopefully by the end
of this week coming from temor our man
in the UK he's gonna be playing well
gear survive and reviewing it for us but
yeah so far as mentioned earlier Ben is
having a shockingly fun time yes a bite
worried used by it what the hell was
that
so I walked right past a dude on pound
can't even see that guy speed him up
give me that coupon energy needs it
flip best best upgrade on definitely
getting that that faster gathering mmm
it's my favorite thing yeah I picked
that chair up that bottle get put that
rich here in my bag everything
everything is good you got you know what
just take the table - yep everything's
good need the wood and the nails Eric
Paree says the graphics aren't the best
but he still plays it because he likes
survival games yeah it's interesting to
to see maybe even how many people are
big fans of survival games trying it out
who aren't necessarily like Metal Gear
fans so spending a lot of time kind of
in the the right like just trying to
like read through threads and like gauge
everyone else's reaction because I can't
pin down is it is it divisive or is it
more like in the
since that or the feelings that you have
or is it really just kind of like all
over the place so there are people who
are still going off of like beta
impressions and they're like ah this is
not what this game should be and then
there's also people who are like me who
are like hey yo this is kind of fun
what's going on here and then there are
people who are still kind of like I
tried it didn't like it mm-hmm
it's it's still kind of all over the
place my primary weapon holder machete
so you you get blueprints for upgrades
from those boxes like that mm-hmm which
is always a thing that's good how
someone wants this to have a battle
royale so I keep saying it I think that
the best game engine candidate for
battle royale would definitely be like
Mel gear just the way that everything
moves and works in this game lends
itself really well do what I think you
know they're gonna do it yeah probably
it's it's well also it's like the new
fad yeah his battle Royales right like
we had a phase where was MOBAs then we
had a phase of you know like hero
shooters or you know tactical team
shooter type things and now I feel like
we are in the world of battle Royales
and that is the next kind of like you
know Froyo yeah yeah hokey-pokey place
you know so this game is out already
Samuel Crowder it came out Tuesday the
20th actually yeah shocking a lot of
people a lot of a lot of people didn't
know that it happens I forget is this 60
or was it forward it's 40 it's sorted
it's not a full-price thing
however oh yeah you told me this morning
I was like hey Ben should we play the
first hour again can you make a new
character and you were like oh maybe we
should check that out later
yeah and you can't you can't do it
without spending money which will show
you guys that that's a whole nother can
of worms
what other there's I'm assuming there's
other microtransactions then oh yeah so
it's basically like you a coin shop kind
of deal okay
oh so it's either like you earn it or
you just speed things up probably don't
even know if you can earn it because I
haven't
myself retro we won't get into that just
yet we'll just we'll save that for later
it means did you see the Rainbow six
siege outbreak stuff I haven't got a
chance to look at you they're not it's
totally similar but like they have kind
of like crystals sticking in there like
arms and stuff like that so I was like
oh it's Metal Gear survives it's it's
not please please don't kill me I'm
sorry I'm sorry should not have even
drew the comparison I apologize it is
kind of a weird thing the the style
choice for having crystals I guess it's
a coup by yeah whatever they are so of
the interesting thing actually the the
monster design of this game was done by
the Silent Hill guy oh so it kind of
makes sense like looking at it and being
like oh yeah kind of looks like it fit
into a Silent Hill game yeah oh yeah
yeah a lot of people saying there was a
not too much advertisement for this game
that's true I mean outside of like the
two betas I believe that they had yeah
there probably wasn't much out of that
and I mean let's be honest here a lot of
people in general are so upset I think
that Konami just from this standpoint of
you know oh they're making a Metal Gear
game you know taking one and kind of
like you know this is my wording okay
kind of bastardizing like a franchise a
little bit that's yeah just what people
like people's feelings you know people's
it's my my joke all the way up until the
game's release was they taken the Metal
Gear series and basically turned it into
like a weird zombie husk of itself kind
of like the enemies in the game I guess
in a weird sort of Kojima esque
metaphorical twist but yeah and yeah we
don't need kind of tough like we don't
even know how far you are in the game
yeah just like you survived and you've
done you played this many hours roughly
oh there we go there's a hard thing to
make whatever that was it how much gila
tree thing been going because that
looked pretty extensive when we saw the
beta and it was like oh which path do I
want to go down
so there's actually even more stuff in
this one that I haven't even
gotten access to oh yeah because you
basically you'd go over here and you
check it out let's get in the hyperbolic
trainer so all over all these things
these are all like the basic survivor
skills but then you can actually branch
out into like four different classes oh
wow oh right yeah yeah I remember a
medic there's like a tank but I haven't
even gotten to those yet so you get like
special abilities and they give you like
if you go down a certain tree you can
like really yeah that's like weird weird
abilities that are kind of over the top
but I'm kind of down with but Bob I'm
not sure when the actual review will be
up in the review in progress aiming for
end of this week again it's hard to tell
how far you are in this game as Ben has
mentioned so yeah we'll see we'll have
to see uh but yeah I think if you like
survival games you're in your metal gear
forty bucks seems fair Jimmy but I mean
like I haven't played that much of it so
it's just really like if you like those
two crossovers maybe the other way you
can I guess sort of track what you're
doing is it there's a it's their story
chapters and I guess I progressed
another one because I was attentive like
yesterday before I stopped playing but I
guess I'm in Chapter eleven okay
so just kind of moving along with it but
I will also get jump into this
conversation about black panther because
I feel like I am I'm I'm more in the
minority I guess have you watched it yet
I haven't yet okay then I'm gonna look
away from the chat yeah I'm not gonna
specifically talk about spoilers or
anything I'm I'm on the fence that I
think that it's a a solid Marvel movie
that is above average but I'm not buying
into all the hype that everyone else has
has said because like everyone's like
you've got to watch it it's like the
best Marvel movie and I'm like yeah not
for me I guess I don't think it's the
best in my opinion but hey that's me and
there's no come at me come at me
opinions or a thing that people are
allowed to have on the internet
especially just remember on the internet
mine's more important because it's the
Internet
do you feel like that character graphics
look downgraded from five I'm sorry to
Ken thinks that but I think the the
graphics like the fidelity of it all
kind of still looks the same the one
thing that's gotten me really perplexed
is the fact that we've somehow made the
Fox engine run worse okay
in that sometimes you'll get like weird
like like FPS drops so like five or ten
and it's kind of noticeable but I always
thought that like the Fox engine was
like super good and there's no way you
could possibly make it not like to do
what it was supposed to do but
apparently they found a way yeah well
you can yep
Oliver need that yeah yeah it's real
nice
give me that pile of steel or whatever
it was hmm and this this weird
lock-picking minigame that isn't even
like lock-picking it's just open up yeah
you almost failed there so that's the
weird thing is it's it's not a fail as
much as it's because the lock-picking
itself is just the beginning part where
you're spamming x mm-hmm
you're just trying to open it so you
don't make noise okay Cajun agent 71
saying this is not a Metal Gear game it
is a poor-man's entries to the zombies
universe that dying light Dead Rising
and Resident Evil have done so well set
um I don't think they really mirror the
games that you just mentioned but it's I
mean come on guys let's be real here
there's something called business
there's something called it a you know
big franchises and you're more likely to
play said game because of a franchise
let alone it's John rrah so Ben likes
Idol gear I got got hey but you what
you're liking it I yeah
think about how mad I mean I I don't
know maybe I always say this because I
think it's still a bargain but it may be
like at the end of the day forty dollars
there's still a lot of money well it's
not 60 bucks at least what if they said
hey you survived like they could've did
that now I don't know if they would have
even like I'm probably I'm sure they're
struggling already kind of but like that
would have been even worse you know what
this this kind of feels like actually it
feels like if they took under
and they did take on dead nightmare and
sell it separately it's kind of like
that mmm okay um maybe that's why I've
been able to put up with it more is just
cuz I kind of thought of it like that
yeah I was like I kind of like these
he's like weird like dungeons that you
do I've only done one of them okay oh
yeah chair I rescued a kid last night
and we brought him back to the base oh
that's why he's like laying on the
ground
yeah who's like oh thank you for saving
me I'm so happy that someone came and
got me from those monsters and then he's
like oh my wheelchair where is it and
then everyone's like oh no we left the
wheelchair behind so now we have to you
can craft all these things Ben yeah a
wheelchair oh I can't make a whole bunch
of stuff the wheelchairs are beyond me a
mere 1991 X SDA and YouTube chat asking
is the story mediocre based on your
gameplay it's it's not like oh this is
the best story I've ever heard but
they're doing a good job of kind of
carrying you through it mm-hmm it's
enough to make me kind of be like yeah
sure all right
like good enough yeah it's not Oh
jump-scare moments like that get off me
King of Diamonds 7 wants to know where
did the animal go animals go when you
Fulton them this is your base right yeah
do they just do they actually show up
like it has de still the same for animal
or is he just kind of like you get that
whatever at first you they just take it
and they give you the the stuff back but
uh definitely later on you can start
raising animals we got zoo yeah you guy
build a zoom all right Bella zoo so I
got a potato farm going on right now but
looking to build off into that Angelo
booty says should we expect a metal gear
card game soon I would doubt that I say
that only because I feel like a lot of
that was the other thing that people
were trying to to get on that train that
hearthstone train yeah and I don't think
most people have fared - well I wanna be
wanna be that guy guys but oh there's a
wheelchair I flip in Metal Gear beat
everyone of that punch a long time ago
cuz we have to acid games that then it's
done
but yeah a Medicare card game would be
kind of kind of weird interesting I mean
I'm not saying that you should accept
the fact that big businesses are trying
to shove these games down our throat
Havok strawberry I'm just saying like
hey it is a reality
yeah and I'm not saying it's a good
thing I'm just saying like logically
like because and I feel like I'm a very
logical person like I I was like yeah I
could see that there's a point where you
just gotta kind of be like yeah this
business say they want to do it you know
why even play this go play something
good like destiny - yeah just kidding he
says just kidding Monster Hunter boy
boys my dude yeah my new exhaust and a
okay I finally got a rank eight okay
switch axe gem I'm feeling good yeah I
just don't know what to put it in
getting that min/max life yeah that
min/max life going is going on I really
need a up well I need a stupid day or a
gem that's one and two I really need to
get the stupid polished gem which is
like really rare to drop because
apparently I don't know if you know but
apparently handicraft is the way to go
these are new who we got an Espada yeah
you know creepy Kurt there's a lot of
them I know what yeah and it's like the
spider got cut in half I think you
should I was gonna say you should maybe
Molly these guys you know cuz like right
arachnophobia would say that you know
you gotta melt them there's so many wait
do we need to even kill them scare
tactic you know that in Dark Soul there
were a hundred percent be like the mama
version yeah right except you know yeah
go to the fire yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like fire ooh a shotgun
yeah totally is shotgun get out of here
yeah you know like fire huh how come Oh
is everything to your level it seems
like everything so be whatever you scale
it seems that way right cuz like the
other dude you're fighting or 13 as well
oh this is the fun part of this right
now for me because the microphone on my
my vital stats are covered up so I get
the call out tonight I know what I'm
hearing huh oh I thought you were gonna
tell me the fun part was us go
and looting all the I'm starting to
think that maybe I'm not gonna live all
these really we stopped after this one
why not look at how many there are bond
you got it you got it all you know what
would be a nice quality of light update
even though I know they'll never do it
because this is a survival game you need
that hot diablo 3 where you hold square
and you guys everything comes in
everything did you get everything yep
suck it in our warp our warp portal
should be able to suck all these in and
give us all the coupon I just want to
warp this entire area actually you know
what this will probably work out because
I'm gonna need to refresh my oxygen and
you need to spend come on there you go
see it all comes together like a circle
boom comes full circle
yeah and then a perfidious danes has all
friends flop at one point or another
this could be that breaking point you
know he knows who knows just trying to
take a take a look at chat thank you
guys all again for all your comments
good or bad Wow broke squid one just not
like Monster Hunter that's fair you know
what that's fair it's understandable as
much as I love it
I understand people who don't like it
yeah where the heck of these coming from
from above your spiders man what are you
well I'm calling spider
Austin Jackson oh game of the year right
now it says month for Monster Hunter uh
yeah it's got a big one to fight come
end of the year it granted I got delayed
I don't think it'll get delayed past
2018 yeah it's gonna be a tough one to
beat Red Dead I think this year I feel
like I'm I feel like Monster Hunter
might be like like near for me where I'm
gonna feel good if it makes it to the
top - no dude it's def there's no way
it's gonna be like I mean this is my
opinion again I have to you know cover
my butt but I feel like at least for
right now outside of all cuz I'm not
looking at a list of all the games
coming out this year I think it'll make
top 5 yeah I think I think because I
hope it does because it's the one
Monster Hunter that's come out on a
console that is accessible for so many
people yeah and look at how many people
started playing the game right like I
feel like that's when you know that you
have like something good going on is
when it you have that ability for so
many people to then play it right and
like I'm a first timer and I'm really
into it like I got off the destiny train
which is kind of a dying game
unfortunately and I played that forever
right and you know Monster Hunter filled
that itch for me in like you know the
same vein and I know John Luke's playing
it for the first time you know you have
all these first-time we're just coming
to the to the franchise and and mostly
enjoying it I'm not I can understand why
it's not for everyone though because it
still has kind of a wonky camera
depending on how you look at it and
combat can be a struggle if you're not
into it and if you don't find a weapon
that you like one of my friends that
played through all of neo you know like
he gave it a shot and was like I can't
do this I was like that's fine like it's
not for everyone obviously same with
this game probably not for everybody
this game is maybe yeah yeah no I'm just
really happy to see Monster Hunter doing
well that's a that's a really cool thing
to me love and acid3 Davy Davy are you
okay and I was you know if you like
again acid it's good good on you but
it's not a it's not for me come when
does not simply watch it monster honey
of the video they play it i watch video
still like I'm actually really stoked
about how much I've like seen you at
your desk like look looking stuff up and
yeah like cuz like I'm like I keep
thinking like I got I gotta be farm in
this room no no because I but every one
last time i was chatting about it to
they're like nah Capcom's got the desire
sensor yep and you're just getting
wrecked by the desire sensor I'm like
yeah that's probably true and that's
probably that's not shocking Andrew you
know it happens they have a bigger
subscriber base so it's true you have
more people your friends there yeah I'm
sure I'm sure uh thuggin with Duggan
doesn't say James is on Tommy's a scrub
yeah tell them that can we can we PvP
them
yeah where's home out where's our batter
around here I would like for Ben Janka
to come at him let's get another was a
battlefield one back when that that beta
was going on yeah DLC doubt this it
would bring it back and we'll bring it
back that was that
fun time yeah gem 76 destiny - needs to
be a bad oh oh is that spider mama it is
oh oh I told you real close to me wait
is that the same thing that was walking
by you earlier or is this something else
us this is the same thing that was
walking by me earlier it's huge
it's got like a like a weird long
stomach yeah I don't quite understand
exactly the clauses have been to it with
legs
it's got like cheese and it's got
another section these huge sections long
is this monstrosity got too many that
that's uh yeah you just come out of
places usually and it pops up and you're
like well I want to deal with this I'm
gonna go hide cheap tin uh asking why
are people hating on this game I played
the beta and it was awesome uh you know
cuz it doesn't have kijima on it people
you know love them their metal gear and
they probably feel like they're hurting
the franchise by having this kind of
game I guess yeah is that is that fair
they get that mostly right it I feel
like I'm betraying a thing that I love
playing it and the fact that I'm
enjoying it is side yeah you should
you'll feel bad about it you damn
traitor I can't believe this you're
traitor
yeah I don't know I I also like kind of
like the weird callback stuff I've Utley
have like in the in the very beginning
like the guy who shoots the rocket that
blows up the helicopter the big boss is
on you snipe him in the head so he
doesn't shoot the helicopter like little
things like that like the was it the
nurse that you rescue was like Oh in the
ambulance on my way to the hospital but
when we got there it was on fire I'm
like that's my boy Volgin I know what's
going on there but like I don't it's
kind of interesting that it kind of can
exist on its own like you could tell me
this is not a Metal Gear game and I
totally buy it
yeah all right what's up five nights at
whiskers how are you doing
I miss acid I never finished the tree is
there even a third one yeah anyways Wes
lee says spider centipede it's pretty
close pretty close it didn't have the
feelers on the like the I don't know
what do you want to call them yeah
stomach II type part I
the yeah not up on my spider Anatomy I
can't totally say your full-name but the
brain insert word 3 2 8 how do weapons
work do you find them or craft them
crafts yeah and you probably unlock more
stuff down the road to craft I would
assume yes so the different stuff you
find those those boxes and those pretty
much are the things that have the
schematics and them you also get stuff
from story progression with the
lock-picking yeah with the lock-picking
yeah so you find the schematics and then
you you take your materials and you
build what you get if I like hue-hue are
we dang I think it's by weeding if I
liked phantom vein do you think I will
like metal gear survive like is there
way less features or anything uh
let's see if anything features wise it's
got a pretty good campaign ah shoot are
you safe or do you get attacked while
you do this lever so the whole thing
like I said this is not necessarily
shoot it's not lock-picking its yep then
it makes noise and then things find you
that's fine he's a low tier wanderer but
though then all of a sudden more come
out and then you've got a deal with them
and I now we coupon farming I'm I'm
encumbered so I'm like trying to not
know there's a lot of okay I lied
there's a lot there's like five I'm just
gonna weapons loud at least one more
rather nailed it headshot three twenty
four twenty noscope give it gun sixty
God numbers to forty four to thirty two
why did it do less the second time I
don't know who knows that bullet was
worse see ethical pixel grats on your
rank eight stone force which thanks
thanks I appreciate it
that's no small feat that's I got lucky
though is my third no poor third or
fourth like rank eight stone first one
was a hammer I was like is this a sign
is the game trying to tell me it's time
to switch and then I got ranged weapons
and I was just like are you come on I
the way I looked at it was I thought it
do like that thing where it's like I
thought like hey I think that you want
to play what you're doing dual blades
and I was like those are the only two
weapons I would possibly sooc to and
then they didn't give it to me anyway so
it's like Benjamin tie-dye or ties are
how tedious is the gameplay systems so
at first I would say that the the hunger
and thirst stuff is kind of annoying
because you can't like filter water so
you run the risk of drinking something
and getting sick or you can't really
cook stuff that's really good but once
you get like the upgraded cooking area
you can make soup which are ponies like
punishes both you'll start to learn more
places where more more animals are and
it becomes more manageable but the
beginning part it's kind of kind of
frustrating yeah but not all right all
right no worries brain the brain three
to eight we got you what is it oh here
Benjamin I again follow up question is
it like Monster Hunter where you keep
getting surprised by the technicalities
of the game so I feel like like they lay
out everything pretty well at the
beginning and you you kind of understand
their it doesn't expand too much outside
of like I know how these systems kind of
function in this world and then you can
kind of go from there but it it's kinda
Monster Hunter II like you're you're
going out to get stuff to make new pants
which you still haven't gone what do we
do oh you do oh but I don't have enough
animal weather oh come on then I'm so
close to having my pants there any
melding person that we oh these are just
the pants from Metal Gear Solid 3 sick
I'm a urban combat pants looks like
we're gonna make some animal leather oh
yeah you can make them oh no you're
gonna farm some pretty much restrain man
you always told me it's all about make
always about making pants it's true it's
all about the pants maker game Eric
Paree I have no idea if you can ride
that one
who knows the brain three to eight again
are there other giant monsters probably
that's the only one you've seen so far
so they just brought a launch trailer
that I processed before I came in home
and they show some stuff in that launch
trailer that I had no idea existed Wow
spoilers there are things in this game
that you don't know about spoiler alert
uh so maybe don't watch it or maybe
watching maybe that's what we get you
know the Brad looking trailer oh yeah
but yeah they show some other stuff in
there hashtag fortunately no scope yeah
I don't know what kind of forever sure
I'll what kind of forever sure yeah if
you guys have questions or anything like
that hit us up Northern Irish fruit
where the f is Monster Hunter Mondays
it's not Fridays that it's true we
didn't get to fry a movie because that's
when the like resets happen so then like
luckily for me like Zora Magna Rose was
the one of the events this week and I
needed the gem for the stupid handicraft
one it took me like six runs to do that
thing done but turns out heavy artillery
gems are the are the ticket for that you
do like 50 more damage per cannon by
yeah it's it's really interesting how
you can kind of stack stuff to make that
game yeah so that's where it that's
where it is Northern Irish crude
comeback Friday's van and John Luke are
still still playing that hot Monster
Hunters they got that did you get the
right costume last week did you get
least Messing yeah I don't have any
saves and I was like yeah I feel like I
have all this other stuff to do already
and I'm like I don't know I can't be
doing that right now
also like I just realized I was looking
at the Street Fighter thing or like you
get you know you can earn the cost like
reverse obviously monster costumes
industry fire you know it takes a whole
month to get the entire set I was like
are you kidding me
so even with that I was trying to get
the beautiful Joe one that the diversed
one you got water
yeah no it's dirty water though you
would think that these barrels would be
you got a boil I got this upgraded
campfire area where I can go in how much
how much how much gross water can you
cook at one time oh it's pretty fast
okay you can stack it alright you would
think those you would have technology
that you would have built it here in
those you know barrels to
filter the water yeah that's fine I mean
we're not in the future I wanna say last
night I discovered the technology to
create mashed potatoes stick that's good
working towards that I still know how to
get milk I gotta find a cow probably I'm
Hassan or Hassan Khan it brings to a
good point it's all about your
preference either you like it or you
don't from your own experience in games
I totally agree I mean there are always
gonna be games that some people like or
love a lot more than others and that's
the beauty of video games you know like
we have such a thing for everybody
exactly we are so spoiled now I feel
like compared to like in the past you
know that we have such a wide range of
games to play I think we take that for
granted same with like yesterday it's
just like out breaks out and it gets
delayed an hour or two and people are
just salty like why isn't it out it's
free yeah please just let them relax a
bit they told you it's gonna get delayed
an hour
can you please relax no we are entitled
but now because we're the internet
producer kid I wonder why is $40 cuz it
had to be some price because I know that
they they couldn't get away with selling
it for six down no way and they probably
wanted more than 20 yeah so you know
forty is this game open-world ask
narutards very open world that's the
really cool thing to that I'm kind of
into is I I think this is just the
Africa map from five maybe but I can't
tell because of the way that the fog
works I get a really cool feeling of
like exploring stuff from this game that
isn't a thing that I've seen anywhere
else it's kind of kind of weird to
describe ETA moshi-moshi in YouTube Chad
wants you wants to know do you prefer
the other Metal Gear games like Metal
Gear 5 at the phantom pain or this style
do it prefer which one do you prefer I
prefer my Medicare by one through 405
was a good time but I need more I need
them to take Oh
want more cutscenes I want more dumb
over-the-top stuff okay I hate them I
want quiet playing in some water and
dancing and then having that then be
Norman read it no I want Norman Reedus
in a shower okay that's what no I I like
the way that Metal Gear Solid one
through four kind of our things that you
can sit there and watch a lot and
there's a lot of story to kind of take
in benjamin Maloney and I don't know if
you know the answer to this because you
haven't played that much multiplayer but
do you know if the multiplayer has more
game modes than just protect the drill
on different maps yeah I have no idea I
saw that they in single-player they've
started to make me do those missions but
by myself in the story so maybe they'll
show other things but it's pretty much
been that so I can't answer that I guess
full you played both itself self fre oh
yeah got me wants to know Metal Gear
Survivor Monster Hunter yeah Monster
Hunter I haven't played this game but I
got one sir yeah count pickles wants to
know do you think this game will have
some weird ties to death stranding what
with all the alternate dimensions stuff
I don't know I mean I'm just gonna say
this like look at a trailer for death
stranding and look up and then look up
in this game there's some weird some
weird stuff going on some weird weird
some weird things
I'm just throwing it out there JJ Monte
or Monta wants to know for someone who
has never played a Metal Gear game would
you recommend it or is there a lot of
backstory involving the previous games
yeah it doesn't have too much backstory
it's kind of like standalone right the
only thing you basically need to
understand is snake built a base the
base got jumped by a bunch of bad guys
and then you got sucked into a different
dimension and that's like all the
backstory you need to know other than
that third no characters that have
popped up besides I saw a big boss at
the beginning Miller was there but
they're all inconsequential an
ill-omened god no don't play this before
you play the other Metal Gear games yeah
I wouldn't recommend
piggy protector in your opinion was this
game worth it sale price yeah put that
campsite thing des camp down here
depending on how much you like you like
survival games forty forty dollars I
feel like forty dollars is a lot easier
to deal with yeah but is that is it
though I mean the fact that you hesitate
it makes me feel like and I'm putting
words in your mouth probably that it
probably wasn't but then like you also
think about like well what's the next
alternative is it thirty maybe but like
there's barely even any games to market
that I can think of that are thirty that
are like look is uncharted the the
standalone I think was 30 or 40 miles a
42 but like I used to have a theory
where I didn't I'd say man
I'll buy any game for five dollars I
will literally try anything as long as
it's five dollars ah and then I bought
face breaker and I played that and it
changed my outlook on everything yeah
okay gaming if I missed your question I
apologize send that question again and I
will try to read it if you put question
in front of any of your questions that
makes it easier for me to kind of pick
out the questions you ask an ill omen
saying no offensive games BOTS or
anything but this is a peer crash
cash-grab yeah
I'm not talk about that yeah I think I
think we all know that right I'm not
offended by that statement at all
because I'm looking at these recycled
assets from Metal Gear Solid 5 put into
a thing and I'm like man yeah no worries
JJ thanks for asking a question thanks
for stopping by and tuning and
appreciate it yeah
[Music]
see I got to start building around this
is a real real issue I can't do it there
have to destroy this uh hi
idk Roselle saying I'm playing this game
and I'm three hours in and I like it
yeah I think um there's gonna be people
that enjoy it I think and sometimes it's
hard to give these games a chance even
if like your Metal Gear fan you know
because you might just be so upset
what's wrong
I give me a seven to make corn oh you
make corn we can grow icky I can't do X
I don't have corn I need corn before I
can make corn of course what was how
could you how could you possibly make
corn if you don't have corn to begin
what exactly you when do you get the
subclasses he's like ten eleven hours in
and still doesn't have it right yeah it
hasn't shown up yet
here we go now I can upgrade my gear
bench this is good yeah you think you
can craft anything new because of that
maybe we'll find out here so yeah this
is the other aspect of the game
obviously you know building your base
upgrading your base so that you can you
know craft and all that fun so I could
make a jungle hat now that I can't see
because I'm wearing an eye patch but I
refuse to not wear that eye patch I can
make the diamond dog gauntlets now I
still can't make my pants cuz you need
to go out and get the animal leather
that I was gonna get I can actually go
run over and punch these sheep knock
this thanks for stopping by at that 15
yeah pretty sure this game is gonna get
a sale for 30 maybe I feel like the
price is probably gonna to go down who
this is alright hey are you able to
access microtransactions right now
somebody's at so John guy is asking what
are your opinions of the
microtransaction I okay I can try to go
to the store okay if you can't not a big
deal I think that the one kind of
appalling thing which I find totally
weird is when you told me that it takes
it costs $10 to make a new character a
second character yeah I believe that's
the case which if that is the case which
will double check here in a second if we
can is bonkers to me you paid $40 for a
game
why wouldn't you be able to make another
character like what what do you mean you
gotta pay $10 million other character
yeah all right so we've got what we got
here oh these are just premium boost
passes I only I tried to load this menu
up the other night and I just crash I
crashed my game so you get faster energy
should resource production booster and a
battle point so is this just from you
buying the game no this is all stuff
that you have to get with the the coins
yeah we would have to buy the coins
right yeah so that that's a different
store completely let's look at your coin
history looks so much Bitcoin have
seconds take a look here ah yes just as
I assume it's good good you're not
paying job good good see here so oh you
know I understand an ill omen I can tell
when somebody is trolling or versus
being realistic I totally understand it
is completely I agree with you I'm not
gonna argue here we go yeah oh yeah so
$10 to get eleven hundred coins basic
okay so where did you see the thing
where you had to make another carrot oh
is that like the load is when I'm making
something out but yes so when you come
back here sick did it auto save by the
way yeah okay good good I also just did
a hard save but so you're at the
character select screen and you got your
first character you've made and then if
you go over to the right it cost a
thousand coins that's like 10 bucks yeah
it was 1100 right yeah to get a new me
you new character and you don't and so
far in the game you have not unlocked
this currency right no I haven't done
any of these these coins oh yeah that's
that's real real not good oh alright
let's go back to the game so I can stop
making that bad noise butts that's fair
it's it's worth checking out but yeah 10
10 more dollars to make another
character space cadet Adam has a pretty
good question in YouTube chat question
is is this game online only or can you
play without internet connection from
what I've been hearing it's online only
and that if you lose your connection
kicks you out I've also heard people say
that if you're in multiplayer and one
person loses to your connection it
pushes everyone out to the menu which is
not good
can you play sorry you might answer this
and I was just looking at chat so
apologies
so can you play single-player without
anything I don't think so okay can you
co-op open world no it's only the
multiplayer maps yeah
which so far we've only seen that like
defend the drill or whatever right it
would be really great if they they did
like a co-op in this area which is what
everyone thinks or at least what I kind
of was hoping or hoping for and yeah so
no co-op outside of the like defend them
oh look he's you put him to work yeah
he's just doing doing doing all the
stuff he needs ooh virtual cops more fun
more better than this game hey me every
cop does a legit game by saying
literally just make oh did I just make a
micro transaction building yeah it's
just a goddamn micro transaction builder
there's nothing else oh wait hold on
hold on this is none of crew members
okay okay
you didn't supply it if you want
multiple unit for some more people out
oh my lord
okay well so I'm guessing this guy's
probably good for that's hilarious
exploration team hey guess what guys we
can make a my connection building like
Rudy's you can send Chris out in his
wheelchair to go fetch you some loot
maybe want to why you need animal skins
he's look he's having a good time not
gonna show you rather him make some corn
for you or potatoes or whatever oh with
this so this you send people out on
missions okay so this is why you want to
save people yeah this is like your you
know World of Warcraft your garrison
yeah my right ear or your tail rider
crew so to speak someone put him in
there even though he's sick he's
definitely infected a hundred percent
hundred percent infected he survived
seven days though yeah he's been here
for a while he's the first guy you meet
but uh you know what I'm just gonna send
him by yourself yeah go for it dude
collect me animal skin give me this
animal scoffs oh no useless he can't
even get me the animal skin that I want
what good is he
and I know what are you short on I'm
just gonna get wood woods always useful
yeah go get that wood it's not meet the
missions recommended levels my dude yeah
just go for it just he'll be fine
what could what could possibly go wrong
can't do can't even this guy get out of
here the interesting thing is he's
actually uh he's a member of Zoff so
he's like the bad guys from alive so
he's the first person you run into and
you're like oh I'm from motherbase oh
I'm from the people who tried to blow up
your home and you got that kind of thing
going on giving hip hop says I was down
for this game till I found out no real
co-op and ten dollars for a new
character when you already bought the
damn game yeah I yeah I didn't expect
that I was like yeah we should play the
first hour you know give people the
taste and then you're like yeah well
about that and then no expense a new
character yeah I probably could have
told you to do that I wouldn't have been
happy about it but uh yeah it's funny
that you got a building they can spend
somewhere
yeah that's bucks at oh there's no
person to to rescue let's do yeah we
need that we need a crew
we need alpha team needs to get bigger
exactly to get everyone and everyone all
together
go on over here my teleport I hope that
that's not the case
whitey snakey says knowing Konami
they'll be looking at shutting down MgO
online or mg oh sorry as some vain
attempt to move people in the isthmus
what no real co-op well there's no like
mission yeah but like we get you can
open your old world stuff in which
that's what they would do cuz like that
would have been the thing this is the
gimme like this is what everyone wants
hey we're learning things as we go
Wesley so he basically is calling you
out cuz he said that for someone that is
enjoying the game he sure is complaining
a lot but he didn't know that you could
build a microtransaction building it's
true so there's that so I mean how white
night him I'll be your white knight
exactly it's the Internet we just
discussed this we're all about
complaining on the Internet
why why else would we be on the internet
right often B's blog slash gaming says
how good on this game would you rate
this I don't know we're not gonna do
numbers now we're won't do numbers we'll
do like a I don't know basically God
what we've been saying is if you enjoy
survival games and Metal Gear games this
might be up your alley
however if neither those really tickle
your fancy probably not the game for you
yeah there's there's nothing for you
then if if that's kind of where you are
yes as a perfect disdain has mentioned
co-op is instanced missions so far the
only ones we know about is the like
defend the drill now on different maps
there could be more because this is the
full release but Ben's been primarily
playing this is a single-player because
you know that's what I probably would do
it the single-player I feel like is
better than the co-op I feel like the
co-op said good if you need to get like
some materials some stuff like hanging
out with your friends it's I don't know
if it's the focus yeah Hasan Khan
dropped in some pretty good advice to
the chat remember everyone by games with
smart decisions do your research and
learn from your experiences it's your
time and you don't want to waste it
because you won't get it back these are
fair and proper words definitely good
things to take to heart yeah
yeah let's see any other a lot of dudes
over here hey you got can you guys show
the four gold weapons Thanks
well he's got gold bad they've got my my
gold bat we can we can check it out here
in a bit
oh man it's you it's dropping from there
you know what their question marks is
that bad no the question mark is the
person I'm saving here we go what's this
[Music]
don't need my fire arrows become Legolas
I'll begin with me how many do you have
looks like you have eight and I've 0 and
you are west of taking your archery
classes all right all right hey friends
could you show a little bit of the skill
tree ask you Nate nice go gaming nice go
gaming we can do that when we get back
to the base next we're gonna have to
take this person back yeah that's a sure
you like the right because I haven't
gotten it yet but if I keep getting this
this energy maybe we'll knock it cuz
maybe it happens it like 20 or something
but I can it's basically the same one
from the beta that I have mmm we can we
can look at it though
noctus chiming in people play destiny
tune complain and so it's fine to
complain yeah I complain about destiny
too all the time even though I'm a
defender I feel like well I'm less of a
defender now but I wanted to be like one
of those one of the guys that like you
know like hey yeah like I've defended
this game for a long time see it is good
yeah it's long it's can't thank you I
feel like if you love something you
should be able to critique it a little
slickster 15 says I hardly see any other
enemy types yeah there hasn't been too
many the spiders that we saw earlier
were newer I could head over to a
different area cuz there's there's also
like flies that shoot lasers that I've
summarized that shoot lasers those
spiders that we ran into which I don't
think I'm
Bano the big thing that we saw earlier
now there's there's definitely more
little slickster you just haven't seen
them all but in terms of like for us in
in on this stream so far gameplay wise i
think it's only been these kind of like
wanders and the spiders but you know as
been mentioned there's there's other
ones there definitely those those blowup
ones that you want to try to like stab
in the back at least I've seen in
multiplayer so I would assume they're
also in this I just want to count that
that's scary big thing that we haven't
seen yet again mmm
what does this game taste like not sure
if I could tell you I would I know
got it digitally so I can't I can't tell
a space cadet atom question how does
this melee combat feel considering it's
a new mechanic compared to the games
based on that it's kind of clunky
admittedly but the more you unlock the
more kind of works so give you like you
can do leg sweeps or you can do like an
extra combo attack or things that make
it a little bit more bearable and that
and some of that skill tree based yeah
right yeah one of the most important
skills is the Dodge and you have to
unlock it through through the skill tree
mmm
soul fan Nefario Yagami Yagami at the at
does it get harder at night I haven't
seen the difficulty go up it's just much
more difficult to see things that go but
if we did like a Dead Rising thing
that'd be kind of really cool later
Hasan Khan thanks for stopping by and
chatting with us appreciate it everyone
left destiny says Kyle Flay
yeah mostly mm-hmm so the gold weapons
we got over here just so we've got a
survival machete that's that's gold
ooh nice pretty this is for you Jack if
I recall correctly 87 attack so it's
it's pretty alright baseball bat yeah
131 I'm still using from the from the
beginning of that whirlwind move pretty
good big fan of it yeah golden survival
spear which is nice it's pretty much
just a survival spear with the gold
collar on it
and a sledgehammer wish I should craft
but it takes the place of my bow so I
haven't been able to protect this issue
and yeah but yeah those were those are
all the weapons that you can yeah dude
it's Matt I could see what you're saying
has to be true he says what sucks as a
gamer and a huge MGS fan is that if this
game had a different title and nothing
to do with damage yes I'd probably play
it but right Konami is milking it yep
mmm-hmm John Smith never saw this game
yeah I didn't get too much
advertisements and there's only been
like two betas so if you didn't hop on
those it's probably hard to know too
much about this game is there fast
travel yes yes so the the one of the
main drivers in the game is building a
network of teleporters Oh Brandon basing
you had to beat single-player story to
unlock the four classes oh thanks
Brandon Bay so I've been trying to grind
up and I shouldn't even be grinding up I
should just be pushing through the story
is there a way to play the story in
co-op mode not right now no I wish I
just want a good multiplayer game to
come out LOL says lego legends i'd
highly recommend monster hunter but if
that's not you or your friends kind of
jam Warcraft got battle for Azeroth
coming up it's gonna be a real heck of a
time I guess it also depends on if you
want PvE or PvP because there's like a
lot of solid my PB like PvP shooters or
like like Rainbow six siege is about to
drop you know they're there year three
update in like a month with a zombie or
I shouldn't call it zombie because it's
not necessarily their zombies but
infected outbreak mode so yeah sounds
like SATA Ness is having fun with the
game that's cool is there any staff
rankings from mgs 5 oh I I don't think
they have rankings as much they have
like so after a person's been at your
base for a while look
you kind of like a break like a breeze
and break down over them like this
person is really driven but sometimes
they need to just focus on one task at a
time otherwise they get distracted and
you're like what does that even mean
yeah let's see
Eric Perry's got a good taste ohmmeter I
guess it tastes like state of decay with
a few tweaks instead of decay is amazing
if you like survivors so that's that's a
fair statement actually I could get done
with that phase in Mehmood how much is
this game $40 or $39.99
yeah Cayla Rose angel no man's sky is a
better game maybe now it's a better game
it went through a lot of iterations and
what's interesting about that is I think
people forgot about it
after the fact but I heard it's a lot
better now yeah John Smith is it like a
battle royale game no it is a survival
game I say give it a little while yeah
you'd be shocked or something yeah then
they'll take the other acronym they took
mgs with this one then they'll take
Metal Gear Rising with milky royale game
of life 4890 do you recommend buying
this game right now or waiting I'm an
MGS fan and I like survival games but it
seems like it may be a bad game well if
you if you're a fan and you like
survival games this might be right up
your alley but if you if you want to
wait I guess the only thing you could
wait for is a discount right but you
have no idea when that's gonna happen
since it just came out my usual thing
whenever someone's kind of on the fence
about getting a game is I'll say hey if
the game looks good to you like if you
if you're seeing this being played right
now and you're like I could probably get
down with that yeah you're probably
interested I'll join ya like if you see
something and it looks bad to you it's
definitely gonna be bad mmm that's fair
it's it's all personal tastes yeah
there's the main base get invaded by
zombies yes
oh you're finding another person this is
good this is given off a squad is gonna
get lit it's gonna be so good so many
people uh so I just realized that I
stab that guy and I didn't fold them is
this metal gear game still stealth based
oh yeah as you saw he kind of snuck up
on that person see there's their stealth
but it's kind of like you're sneaking
around things that don't have heads so
what's their what's their sense of where
you are so it's more sound based and I
guess they do have like a like a line of
sight but it's not they don't act like
people okay they oh I forgot about that
get trip will get a black carrot it's a
thing grab the black hair one above are
you basically building a new weather
base I don't think you're building a new
mother base it's the the whole like what
everyone's trying to do is they're
trying to the soft guy is trying to get
out because he doesn't want to be here
at all the nurse wants to help everyone
that she can and your character just
kind of like there's some weird thing
going on like they're it's like they're
infected with whatever the zombies have
and you're here to like there's you're
trying to uncover what your actual
mission is it's a weird situation that
is very difficult to explain my arm got
cut off but it grew back Metal Gear
Metal Gear rebuy nature I was fairly
disappointing at Metal Gear Solid 5 my
cell or itself
lots of story elements felt unfinished
main villain man on fire
and the parasites felt like a dopey redo
of nanites yeah I agree I I enjoyed
playing five for what it was but I it
just didn't didn't entirely do it for me
yeah Eric Paree you guys making me
hungry hungry for killing heck yeah did
you wreck it
uh I guess been rikes it
I guess I'm still I never tried that
trick I think I'm pretty sure it works
though I'm Petey
did you hear about you know about that
right well which one so in Petey there's
like a part where like you can insane to
the mic like did you write it
oh really and then it like actually like
helps someone I don't know I don't know
if I just that by chance
it just sounds similar but I think Josh
Shaw who used to work here against watch
tested anything I believe it worked so I
know that there was the everyone sick I
know that there was a look part of the
end of the the playable teaser was you
had to like take 10 steps stand still
and then you had to like say the ghost
name mmm and I think that's that's what
I knew it was yeah I still kind of don't
believe that maybe it's just making
noises or something but yeah it's that's
a thing
oh I have just enough beds for everyone
that's good
yeah medical resources definitely more
of those maybe you should send him out
to go get everyone sick everyone sick I
just brought you back why are you doing
this how do you unsick them I think you
have to put medical supplies in the in
the bed through the tents or something
see if the you oh I want to contribute
have a potato has some tarragon maybe
that will help you out I should probably
uh Martin Alejandro Perez
it seems monotone and repetitive does it
have some wow moments during the
campaign I mean the wild moment was when
that freaking big ol Cthulhu thing
walked by yeah I feel like they're gonna
build up to something because right now
everything has just been like oh yeah
it's you know we're trying to survive
and get through this stuff really cool
and then all of a sudden like that giant
thing comes out of the Mist and they're
like oh this is the thing we need to
look out for this is dangerous I don't
mess with it so feel like there's gonna
be some weird weird stuff down okay a
Spartan wants you to know did you know
that you died after having this game for
72 hours
that's the joke I'm already dead
Crimson Trace ntt what platforming
playing this on ps4 yes ps4 this is our
regular ps4 tier so it's not oh gee sage
mentor is a co-op game it's co-op in the
sense that you can co-op multiplayer and
defend a drill at least so far that we
know of but you can't do this portion of
it the like kind of single-player
open-world part with co-op right you a
walker that's mashed up
McKellar a red are washed up washed up I
walk into the wrong thing yeah ever
bought chamber need to train yeah you
could get better I need to get stronger
than that goddamn Goku I'm not sure
Benjamin Kelleher the only thing I've
seen co-op wise and multiplayer is
shootie horde mission type stuff but you
know this is the full release so maybe
there's some other stuff but that's all
I know so far I think they're all still
Salvage missions
maybe space-cadet Adam I don't know if
you've already answered this but is the
game's clothing and gun customization
any good it's I mean I haven't unlocked
a lot yet but they let you change the
color on stuff so you can kind of get
like a little bit of a fashion thing
going if you want to so that's kind of
cool
ultimate question do you believe this is
going to flop yes I think that I think
it will okay the I feel like the damage
has already been done on it and there's
there's no amount of like coming back
from yeah no matter who says this he'll
the battle royale yeah until the battle
right happens dude that would be maybe a
weird one if that's the reason why like
all of a sudden people played it but you
never know they just attach it as a free
update to this game so everyone has to
buy them yeah survive wait is the map
even new or is it the same recycled
desert so that's the thing I'm not sure
cuz there are parts that are definitely
from it whoo do we get to use that thing
yeah pick it up here in a second destroy
anything some wood
but there are parts where you can
recognize like this is definitely a part
of the map but I am just I haven't
played it enough in a while to like
remember it but like it's uh it feels
kind of kind of different nice you know
Walker Eric Paree asking do you guys
know if you're gonna do far cry 5 live
yeah when it comes out we will
definitely do it if we can play early
for some reason we will definitely do it
so definitely stay tuned and stick
around and all not today stick around
but you know down the road comes out in
March right yeah end of March I believe
can you skip time to ignore the Knights
yes Emmanuel then daelin you when you
build the the like tents or whatever for
people to stay in it actually lets you
use them to past time but it drains your
hunger and your thirst when you do it
gotcha iam bragging how does it play
overall please like Metal Gear Solid 5
like it the the controls and everything
are very similar the changes how the
layout is what the get the gameplay loop
of like going out and then coming back
is to something completely unique to
this game and it I I kind of like it
like it works by the way you're you're
hungry captain yeah can i watch it badly
read by nature is a story worth watching
probably not is like I said it's there
and it's enough to kind of drive you
through but it's there's not much that
I've run into outside of like the
beginning cutscenes that kind of like
lead you anywhere
yt sneaky saying and twitch that if you
removed all the microtransactions and
made the game free with a battle royale
mode that might be able to rescue it
well that would definitely rescue it or
if like they just did what fortnight did
right which is like hey the battle
royale you know it is free go ahead play
that and you know if you want to buy
cosmetics go do that oh here we go we
got the we got the bloaters or the
Bombers
this Walker gears about to blow up the
tubes and I'd walk around too much in it
that's the thing so what's the indicator
that tells you that it's gonna do that
because it doesn't look like it's broke
it starts toast barking and stuff when
you're walking around too much
but if I can make it up to that place
there a Russian name that I can't say in
YouTube sorry is there any bosses it
looks like there might be there's that
big guy walking who's that real big guy
might be a thing so pay I can't answer
any of these questions you're asking
because they're not topical and come on
give me a break here Eric wolf I don't
know that do you guys know the PC
version supports sy I don't even think
there is a PC version right this is it
yeah yeah okay it released like the next
day but it it should be there I've
already been here oh god yeah it is out
sorry on Steam $39.99 I do not know if
it's sir it supports that's why sorry
we're playing on ps4 Oh PC version is
out in someone's at 4 hours almost says
3 hours some of them sometime soon it
it's coming out on its way yeah Madeline
Korea so with as far as you guys have
made it this far as it worth playing so
it's all been and feel like you're
having a you know mostly fun time more
than you thought you would it's a board
recommend though yeah which is like I
don't know I actually just looked up
metal gear survived and there's like a
lot of articles like saying like hey
like it's fun but it's also like weird
or like you know like it's you know you
might have to get farther into it you
know to really get into it I'm not
always attaching that to like you like
this but you've got to play five hours
well isn't that like Kingdom Come
deliverance that game came out last week
and I heard the the prelude part of it
the tutorial part of it's kind of like
it's kind of a game full of bugs but
then I heard it also gets better so I
know I still have to try that one out
myself
turn it we're definitely not that gaming
site that you said but we are at
GameSpot but I will answer your question
anyway so this is the review coming for
this it's probably reviewing progress
hopefully by the end of this week from
tomorrow
our boy in the UK and then hard to say
how much longer is gonna take after that
because we're like what our sorry you're
like 10 to 12 hours and now probably
closer to 12 yeah and we don't even know
how far we are and as somebody mentioned
earlier I think was Brandon said that we
can't even unlock the subclasses til we
beat story so so makes me wonder if they
open up some sort of like endgame thing
because why would you give people like
why would you guess yeah you're probably
making like your base probably like
trying to craft better stuff maybe yeah
I'm sure it ties into multiplayer
somehow what did the water dry up they
got taken oh no you got problems oh this
was my water hole I went here all the
time to get my water and now the water
is gone
it's a survival game man surprised what
is this I don't know what about the
Diamond Dogs dogs either
you know there's there's the place
they're here ish I guess in a way I
don't which is really weird actually not
I think about it because that shouldn't
have the Diamond Dogs logo because they
didn't form the Diamond Dogs until after
all the stuff everything's falling apart
this universe is fake nothing makes
sense are their attachments for the guns
I haven't the only thing I have is a
shotgun and a pistol so I don't know
okay know if it opens up later on with
more things but oh
coconut backer or Baker says there won't
be another real Metal Gear and to be
honest could you my lost his touch don't
kill me
haha no kijima wanted out like three
games ago and you didn't want to keep
making them but Konami kept forcing him
to so I'm sure we'll see something Metal
Gear but I don't think it'll be a thing
that is
gonna be good gravy gray where's the
lobby I miss it unfortunately we've
stopped you in the lobby however we have
these fun kind of like chats I guess you
can call them and that we have in the
office that we've kind of been doing
more recently that are kind of like um
stuff that we want you to see that you
know kind of like I wouldn't say to
replace the lobby but it's kind of like
some of those chats that we were having
on the lobby we are not having there
yeah so you know we've done one on
Monster Hunter drag well fighters we're
gonna do one on Kingdom Come deliverance
soon I think in like the next day or two
it's gonna be up on the side and on
YouTube so that's kind of where we're
heading for now so yeah again so sorry
about the mix-up now it's fine you
probably were in the other stream you
just know now yes exactly
yeah pretty much stealth expert stealth
maneuver oh no I can do this
why am i doing that there we go lotion
of emotion I'm sorry if this has been
asked before but what the hell is this
game about I can try to explain the
story set up my guests TLDR me so you're
a soldier on mother base and the attack
happened after ground zeroes where skull
face brought zof over and they pretended
to be the inspection team from the UN
but they weren't surprised and everyone
gets murdered while big bosses away he
comes back finds everyone fighting with
them he gets away and then like as big
boss flies away in the helicopter a
giant wormhole opens up in the sky and
you like everything start to get sucked
up into it and somehow you get like
you're on a crane at the top and you're
about to get sucked in but it closes on
your arm so your arm gets disconnected
through the wormhole and for some reason
it grows back and that qualifies you to
be a candidate for this company who's
been researching wormholes to send you
through to this dimension so they do
that without asking you and now you're
trying to gather all of the information
that the previous research team had sent
in but they've all gone missing
mysteriously and this is random all
right if you had to describe all the
hours of play that you've done so far in
one word what first comes to mind that
was from the link wind it's like a good
kind of grindy grindy grindy Wow I want
to put like a positive connotation on it
but I also am like an idiot who loves
grinding in games and there I know that
life yeah - tears hand every day back in
vanilla
it's killing things for eight hours a
day it was a real mess whoa the
waterhole dried up that's actually a
pretty cool that's a pretty sweet
mechanic says Jasper more oh cool but
now I need to find a new place to get
water yeah you need that see Mitch oh
sorry
see Mitch yeah I just more or less
answered that question about the lobby
just so you don't know it's like a wolf
or something bucks
Oh are we gonna get some animal skin
might I need to get food some side
script jackal meat a cornered side
stripped foxes more dangerous than a
jackal read by Nature do you feel as
though the mechanics added gel well with
the base mgs5 mechanics I wasn't so keen
on the melee in the beta I'd say they do
okay it kind of shocks me a little bit
how well it works and the the melee is
really awkward but you kind of get used
to it and you find weird workarounds
like whenever I hunt anything I always
do the running punch now cuz you will
never hit whatever you're trying to hit
if you're just straight-up me laying
pac-man x5 how's Metal Gear survive at
gamer spot
[Music]
oddly enough I'm having an alright time
yeah I still feel weird saying that oh
you know that's alright is it though
you'll just be judged by the Internet
that's alright you know that's where I
am
I accept it but yeah no animal skins
there no new pants that's all I've been
trying to do 10 10 hours in and still no
pants yeah TV TV Jeep anthem -
interesting economic prices at 48 did
not go the full 60 that's because I
don't think anyone would buy this at 68
no that's that was either by having
enough of a hard time kind of doing this
at 40 but yeah I mean I get my opinion
so who knows a different difficulty
options are just one base difficulty I
wasn't prompted with a difficulty choice
so I think it's just kind of flat yeah
and it seems like so far every like area
that you've gone to your mission that
you've done has been like scaling to you
so the interesting thing too is I didn't
realize how like like lethal things are
in this game if you get cornered by one
dude he can mess you up in like three to
four hits at the beginning which is kind
of a thing to deal with
Ethan George just so you know he says
this is one of the best gaming images
I've ever played
to be fair there might be a little bit
of some hiccups here that over this time
around just based off of Ben's
experience he said he had some some
framedrops ten I don't know how they
managed to make the Fox engine somehow
not run a thing at 60 at one point but
it's it's pretty solid for like 90% of
the time so the little stuff that you've
been doing so far would you say that's
the extent of the stealth that you've
had to use like hasn't gotten like
deeper than alright um there's been a
couple of times where like when that big
thing would pop up and I was like don't
don't go right through him and you have
to kind of like sneak around it stop
them there you go good stuff
no worries gravy gray thanks for
dropping in chat or a question there and
yeah we try to answer so we appreciate
everyone in the chat hanging out and
chatting with us it's actually been you
know what yeah I was sort of like if
you're
surprisingly positive about this game
the chat has been surrounding to say to
a positive just in looking over there I
haven't seen anyone go like goes bad
your bad yeah I mean like most of it is
like you know what we kind of know as
like the negative connotation you have
this game which is like yeah it's a you
know Metal Gear game but really like
play I feel like people are just like by
the name very curious yeah they didn't
show anything of the single-player
before I don't think they showed like
the first three missions which probably
doesn't give you a good gauge or grasp
of like what the game is so yeah I am
shocked though like depending on how
long you have to play to that it takes
you that long to unlock a subclass
because like I would think like that's
like a fun part to kind of get through
assuming that person in chat is you know
not lying to us but like that would be
like a thing that I would think would be
a motivating factor to you continuing to
play right it's like okay cool so like
if I keep leveling I'm gonna get more
abilities for you know tank class or you
know wanderer or that one or sorry like
tank medic etc yeah and then that would
be like the part of the drive for you to
like keep going but I don't know maybe
there's maybe like you said there's
probably a reason it's like you know
when you're campaign it's not really
like that you know but yeah I think
someone asked this earlier and I forgot
the name I apologize somebody I think
asked if you could play multiplayer
right off the bat like you could in in
beta or something you have to point okay
how long did it take to unlock the
multiplayer not too long I don't
remember exactly what mission it popped
up on but it it kind of does like oh
this is a situation where you have to
defend a thing now you can go and play
Salvage missions mmm-hmm co-op
Brendan Bay I don't know if those are
fair comparisons in it I don't think
either of us played something Nautica
did you play something Annika I played a
little bit during the the beta alpha for
it whatever it was it was a long time
ago
404 says you sounded nervous when you
said your gig ante I mean he's a heck of
a he's up he's a mean boy not I'm not a
fan of him he's real dangerous somewhat
Bob wants to see us fight that big
monster by the end of the stream we can
try I don't know if I don't even think
it'll let you
and or I think if it if it does for some
reason it'll one she'll probably just
turn around and step on me yeah but if
we see it again all I'll hit it up a lot
of a lot of people now kind of saying
rip Silent Hill song and he'll deserve
better
we need someone I think that if anything
like I think as much as people are upset
about this game or potentially upset
about this game I think if anything the
greater loss is the fact that there
won't be that it was a silent hill's
game I was gonna say like if if Metal
Gear fans feel like they got did dirty
like no one got done more dirty than
Silent Hill fans like you you're like oh
this could go this could be good Mike my
series is back and it could be very good
wait it's all gone now
it's like it never existed and I can't
even download the demo anymore to play
that if I didn't have it downloaded yeah
exactly
that's game god yeah that exact get a
guy that's writing real Ryan yeah I
guess they're putting that guy to work
though and he's he's making monsters for
me like here's five sites like uh we got
a change tactics here let's put both
series together yeah
have you encountered a metal gear in
this game not the tiny bipedal walkers
I'm gonna go up big ol I haven't run
into any metal gears now I'm gonna go
with a big ol no on that oh actually oh
I do know a thing you know a thing so I
remember it was in like a preview or
something at some point but it's like a
like a a thing you can summon in I
remember seeing like someone callin like
a Metal Gear RAY or something so out
fight stuff okay
when do you how far do you think you
have to get to to get to that cuz I want
to see that that would be sick that
would be game play I would want to watch
I'm curious if if that's like a thing
that I'm just like making up in my head
but I swear to God like I remember them
being like it's like this is what you
dreamed of it was in like a like a video
where there they were kind of discussing
like what the game is and how it works
and they're like or maybe even call down
Metal Gear RAY to to a fight and it
showed him like dropping from this
surprise
and it was a thing yesterday in 67 hey
GameSpot thanks for not being idea and
sure any Tighe ass something like that
I'll say we'll take it thanks for being
you yeah exactly
I assume a lot of Silent Hill ideas
we're going to des training ah I don't
know we'll see it's it's weird to think
that like there's been so many trailers
for deaf driving and yet nobody knows
what the hell that game is Yeah right
I'm afraid actually I'm afraid to blow
that game I don't know man I don't know
I just oh you can summon the summon ray
in the co-op mode 30 PG phantom 2 okay
and Noctis and of course also said that
- you can summon ray I'm pretty sure
cool I'm glad you guys are here to help
me retain my sin that would have been a
sick dream though Yeah right like oh man
remember that time in Mel you're
survivor you call down Metal Gear Rex in
and made him beat up all the zombies
firuze Masood how much death depth met
death jeez how much depth is there to
base building and customization in
general actually the like building
crafting system and all that's pretty
good admittedly like I really like how
you can kind of customize your base
exactly how you want to have it like
laid out build up defenses does it
expand I would assume you're gonna need
more space right yeah let's see the noir
bat says des training also took the
creepy fetus from silent hill's oh
you're right
except it's dead anyways the interesting
thing - there was a point in time where
was it the the decoy in Metal Gear Solid
5 didn't make like a version of what
they kind of watch out
what's your toes what's their toes the
ghost from PT also like apparently
canonically like this like PT happens
the same time there's Metal Gear Solid 5
okay and like the major ground basis for
that is like you can hear the radio
transmission about dad was a real drag
like in five
interesting on a radio Brandon Bay
asking what chapter are you on it's on
the top left of the map screen yeah it's
I think a lemon
well we've advanced another chapter I
looked away moving on up but yeah
why is everything black and white it's
because we're inside of the the dust
zone which shadow fox 364 do you weapons
and gear have durability yes and what
happens is if you kind of neglect the
durability they just do less damage and
work less efficiently over time mm-hmm
so it's not too much of a hassle that
kind of like keep tabs on them and just
repair them every time he kind of check
back and into the base but oh hello
I missed this before nice mister Fibble
says folks still won't know what to
think of this gardening even after it's
out yeah right fried you sounds like a
game made by Hideo Kojima it's me
serious 93 what game or what will you
compare this game to and so far with all
the time played how do you feel about it
once it's data decay yes the key is a
pretty good comparison I mean that's
eric parrey yeah again I mean I've been
asking you how you feel about this game
he's surprisingly happy about it I'm
positive surprisingly positive caught
off-guard by how much I'm enjoying my
time playing it I should probably make
oxygen and also cure myself sounds good
mandus thank you yes they said you can
summon ray as some others have mentioned
thank you Dave ash if you knew what you
knew now would you still spend the $40
on it I think for you yes right yeah I'd
probably do it especially if I knew what
I knew now just cuz I'm a sucker for
anything Metal Gear so I'd I would have
jumped on it either way but I feel like
I'd feel a bit better after knowing what
I know now
Hudson into a chat
thank you for tuning in as always in and
being allowed before mgs5 I would have
been afraid of solo Kojima project as
well but with mgs 5 his team clearly
showed they can do exquisite gameplay as
well yeah so s train 67 hunting so far
pretty on the fence on if I should pick
it up pretty frustrating that the
reviewers couldn't get reviews out
before launch yeah I mean I think most
reviewers have you know got the game day
of and you said I don't think the
server's even were open like right away
right even though the ps4 version it was
supposed to go live like 9:00 but they
had to issue like two patches to fix it
and make it actually run so it's fine
it's been fine now though right so yeah
everything's been been pretty good I
haven't been disconnected or anything in
my time playing but s train 67 so I
would say like the key caveats if you're
thinking about buying it probably are do
you like the Metal Gear series and then
do you like survivor the survivors onra
if there's if you have a passion for
both of those this is probably a pretty
good pretty good buy I think but if you
don't have both or if you only have one
or the other then I don't know kind of
keep watching gameplay or live streams
and kind of try to making your own
decision or sale maybe if you want to if
you want to try it and you're not quite
sure wait for a sale because that's
that's gonna be the easiest way to do it
TPG phantom ii says have you used a car
yet there was one in the trailer yeah
yeah I found there's one point where
Jeep would spawn in a couple of times
and the weird stuff about equipment in
this game is like it it exists but it
degrades the more you use it so you like
you can't just drive a car around the
entire time yeah same like with the
Walker right you have like the limit
time use so it's it's kind of odd I
guess in that way but it works out
Michael Grayson asking what are y'all's
favorite mgs title not including this
one I gotta go all the way back to Metal
Gear Solid myself mainly because I
didn't play too many after that cuz like
somehow to threw me off and didn't make
me want to play them anymore for
whatever reason I think maybe because ii
was made me
kind of felt like I was forced to play
more stealthily when I like the option
of in Metal Gear Solid you could go you
know either way it felt like you could
play either way especially like given
the the items you get after beating the
game you know with the stealth or the
cloaking device or the bandana anyways
that's my favorite I guess for me I like
one cuz it's kind of like the point
where I got into the series that much -
I've probably played the most three is
just very good but I think like deep
down maybe four might be like my
favorite just cuz of all like the dumb
fanservice he stuff in it and like I can
I can recognize the issues with that
game but I still really like it hot cold
soda
is there a katana weapon in this game
well I haven't seen a katana yet but
maybe I mean I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
say never because they're letting me use
a golden baseball bat I should
definitely get this I should definitely
you know I don't use heavy arrows very
much so I can probably just put those
off to the side Oh John kills one one
one in case what do you think they
should remake Metal Gear Solid one to
save MGS I don't think that will
necessarily save MGS but it will
probably make a lot of fans of that game
happy yeah I mean we are going through
like a remake remastering like
Renaissance something something and I
would totally play that if if they did
that and like we'll talk I just want
them to put out a Metal Gear Solid 3
like with the pachinko machine all the
cutscenes from there in the Fox engine
I want a Fox engine version of three
mm-hmm
but I will never see it sweetberry UD
use brie Sheik is this game always
online when with single-player we
believe so right yeah yeah we hold on
you're telling me so I have to equip it
through here apparently Brandon Bay says
you guys should play some online on
stream you'll get good resources and
recipes if you do well
that makes sense actually I mean do you
want to do one I'll give it a go give
one go and then maybe we'll call it
after that or if there's something Oh
people wants to cease then we can can
check that out that's star killer Joshua
so far what do you think about the story
it's nothing super crazy but it's fun
enough yeah it's it's giving me a reason
to keep going mm-hmm
s train sixty-seven thanks for all the
info you're welcome my last question is
if you've gone to try any caught we're
about to there you go Oh boom
Fuji seven hey what's up good to see you
are you going to get the game Erik I
will probably not get the game I'm not
personally huge into survival and for me
I you know outside of like Metal Gear
Solid and like revengeance they're
probably just like yeah and people can
judge me for that that's fine well yeah
actually that's where I'm at with that
moves a staging area for co-op yes all
right good it saves perfect yeah
emmanuel van Dalen are there save points
while exploring yeah there it actually
has a pretty good like autosave
checkpoint kind of thing okay but it it
almost always happens any time you come
back to a base so it's it's usually
whenever you've you've come in after
something just went down so it's it's
pretty forgiving do all things you
collect directly go to your base yeah
yep mm-hmm
don't FSD say is what's worse than
microtransactions our Nintendo $60 ports
like Bayonetta 2 that offer nothing new
to the people that previously supported
it the only thing new there is that you
can bring it anywhere you want but at
what point is portability not a not
necessarily just a thing I think it's a
pretty big thing now I don't know if
yeah I don't know if $60 is fair but
you're getting two games I feel really
good about it like I bought that without
even a second guess but I love Bayonetta
man I've bought the first game three
times at this point damn but where did
that go it was like so important
question is it a good game hard to say
but he is surprisingly
positive so there's that I skipped at
the bottom there I feel like I'm this so
many question off of this
Foxhound logo because everyone's using
it yeah here day one how am i how am I
supposed 23-man can't believe it I'm
that guy is doing work dude he didn't
have time to change out his emblem
because he is too busy actually I play
the game I agree bring back hater